an archaeologist enters the temple
chamber it's clear that whatever's
inside the people who kept it did not
want it found but there are no chests
full of gold and jewels or ancient
artifacts piled in the corners in fact
the room is completely empty except for
one small statue on a pedestal upon
closer investigation it is made of green
soapstone and appears to be carved into
the shape of a seated skeletal figure it
seems harmless and the archaeologist
stares at it until he hears one of his
colleagues talking outside he turns back
to answer them before looking back at
the statue which is no longer on its
pedestal the archaeologist panics and
calls for someone else to come check
this out but he only manages to get a
few words out about the statue's
mysterious absence before he starts
feeling an odd tightness in his chest he
tries to head for the door but
everything starts going dark he
collapses to the floor dying instantly
and just as quickly the mysterious green
statue reappears this time located
directly on the chest of the deceased
scientist awaiting its next viewer
scp-689 also known as the haunter in the
dark was first discovered in the early
20th century as german explorers
searched indian architectural sites for
valuable artifacts the green soapstone
statue only 30 centimeters in height
isn't particularly light but it's also
not large or heavy enough to cause any
problems for those looking to take it
those who have studied it believe that
the skeletal figure which is seated with
its hands clasped over its knees
represents an ancient deity of the
underworld after its discovery the
statue's location was briefly unknown
but it was later obtained by the united
states office of strategic services from
german hands after the end of the second
world war and that's when its dangerous
properties became clear for the first
time while scp-689 appears to be a
standard inert statue this only holds
true if it is being watched by at least
one person when it becomes dangerous as
if it is in the presence of a person who
watches it then takes their eyes off the
statue thankfully
scp-689's anomalous effects aren't
triggered by normal behavior like
blinking but as soon as eye contact is
fully broken like when someone looks
away from it completely the statue will
vanish it will then reappear 15 to 20
seconds later and bring with it a deadly
curse because each time
scp-689 vanishes it takes a life in
under 20 seconds one person who has
previously seen scp-689 and broke eye
contact with it will die spontaneously
the cause of death is always some sort
of natural cause but ranges from mundane
causes like heart attacks and strokes to
sudden ruptures of internal organs
including in some cases every major
organ in the body rupturing at once if
only one person is currently viewed
scp-689 and is alive the statue will
cause their death and immediately appear
atop their body but when there is more
than one possible target the statue
becomes far more dangerous this effect
only works on humans but anyone who has
ever viewed the statue as vulnerable
it's as if it keeps a list of everyone
who has ever seen it and broken eye
contact and when it has that chance it
starts picking people off that list and
it doesn't matter where in the world
they are located the statue has been
shown to be able to teleport long
distances and appear on the body of
someone who might have viewed it years
ago there seems to be no way to predict
in what order the statue will claim its
victim however a disturbing pattern of
who the haunter in the dark decides as
next has emerged when the statue has
choices available to it it seems to
often target a victim who is in a large
crowd that means that in an instant
hundreds of people could see the statue
and become future targets as if every
time an eye is taken off the statue it
could teleport and claim another life
this raises the possibility of a
horrific chain effects scenario where
the statue could teleport endlessly and
rack up a massive body count in mere
minutes which is why the foundation has
become determined that it never be seen
again the cell holding scp-689 is one of
the most secure in the entire scp
foundation because unlike other keter
class objects it gives very little
warning if it is seen it can be gone in
a second with no way of knowing where it
is and depending on how many possible
targets are out there it could be
anywhere in the world that is why it is
currently encased in a large concrete
chamber surrounded by high intensity
sodium iodide lights each of these
lights has a separate power supply so
there is no chance of total power
failure and for those tasked with
keeping it safe it's one of the hardest
jobs in the foundation three people are
on duty at
scp-689's cell at all times two d-class
personnel are stationed inside the
chamber and a level two agent is
stationed in the control chamber the
d-class agents have one job to never
take their eyes off the statue they can
alternate breaks but the statue must
never be allowed to be unobserved for
even a second and because each person
who has seen the statue is a security
risk the d-class agents are equipped
with instant kill devices so they can be
terminated from afar rather than being
potential targets the level 2 agent
meanwhile has a very difficult job this
is one of the most specialized tasks in
the entire foundation because the agent
must be either blind or equipped with a
helmet that completely blocks their
vision which they must wear for their
entire scp-689
shift all control features in the
chamber are designed to be operated by
someone without the ability to see and
the operator is not to remove their
helmet under any circumstances or they
risk termination themselves as a
potential security risk and escape
vector but don't worry even if the
statue still manages to escape its
chamber the foundation has a plan just
don't tell staff assigned to 689 what it
is in the event of a containment breach
or failure of the lights in the statue's
chamber the first priority is to
terminate any d-class or level 1
observers who may have been exposed to
the haunter in the dark this is to
reduce potential targets and while
higher level staff will be retained in
most cases this only goes for the first
containment failure the foundation will
then deploy a retrieval team of blind
agents or those wearing vision blocking
headsets equipped with echolocation tech
they'll partner with d-class observers
to track down everyone who is known to
have viewed the statue the statue will
invariably appear and lead to the death
of one of these people so knowledge of
these potential targets is key to
containment then comes the challenge of
returning it to containment as soon as
the statue is located a perimeter is
established with coverings put up to
avoid any outside viewers catching a
glimpse of it the d-class observers
enter the perimeter and are transported
back to the facility together to ensure
it never falls out of sight until it is
safely back in its chamber and its
containment protocols are put back in
place but what is actually known about
this deadly statue because of how
dangerous and fast-moving the statue is
any attempts to study its properties
must be approved by the presiding
scientists and are carefully scrutinized
the curiosity to figure out its
mysteries is always tempered by the fact
that any scientist interested may be
subject to summary termination should it
breach containment again its origins are
unknown but it is thought to be at least
several centuries old and its form is
believed to be based on a god of the
underworld this would explain its one
function ensuring people make a swift
visit to the afterlife it does not seem
to have any direct hostility towards
humans or scp personnel and has not
given any indication that it is sapient
or intelligent but it does seem to want
to spread as quickly as possible and it
may be able to sense where its best
targets with the greatest potential to
spread are located this has led many to
compare it to one of the scp
foundation's most notorious residents
scp-173 is another statue that poses a
grave danger to anyone who looks at it
the right way similar to
scp-689 it is frozen in place and
requires anyone who enters its
containment unit to look directly at it
any breaking of eye contact can be
deadly and it's more strict in its
definition of breaking eye contact than
689 is simply taking your eyes off for
even a second even to blink is enough to
seal your fate but scp-173 doesn't use
supernatural powers to claim its victim
this large concrete statue instead
becomes mobile and extremely violent
when eye contact is broken killing its
targets by strangulation or breaking the
neck while this entity has killed many
personnel since its containment it
doesn't seem to have the same ability of
scp-689 to teleport to a completely
different location which means it is
actually less of a threat than the
haunter in the dark but the two statues
similar mo of killing when eye contact
is broken has led some to speculate a
connection despite one being of modern
construction and the other being old
possibly even ancient but one of these
statues poses a potential end of the
world scenario which is why the
foundation is so concerned about scp-689
breaching containment
scp-689 might just be among the hardest
anomalies to get back in the bottle once
it escapes if it appears far outside
containment in a crowded scene it now
has hundreds of new potential targets by
the time the foundation tracks it down
to its past location it will have likely
teleported again and there seems to be
no limit to how many lives it can claim
in a set time that means that as it
racks up more targets and teleports into
crowds it could escalate into a major
threat to earth's entire population with
scp-689 seeming to be able to kill
anything that breaks eye contact with it
there are some in the foundation who
wonder if it should be used against the
most notorious captive of the scp
foundation
scp-682
this rage-filled indestructible
regenerating beast has been a thorn in
the foundation side for years it has
cost countless lives of agents and
personnel with its many containment
breaches and so far the foundation has
been unable to terminate it by any
conventional means but scp-689 isn't
exactly what you would call conventional
means it simply triggers an invariably
fatal reaction within the body of
whoever it targets which means it could
possibly be the only thing that could
kill
scp-682 permanently the risks of putting
these two anomalies against each other
are immense though not only does any
interaction with scp-682 carry risks of
yet another catastrophic containment
breach but moving the volatile
scp-689 puts everyone not just those in
the foundation at risk too the proposed
plan involves exposing the two then
immediately turning off the lights but
for this experiment to be pulled off
safely every personnel who has seen
scp-689 must either be terminated or
placed in the same containment chamber
giving the statue no choice but to
eventually choose as cp 682 to improve
the chance of success the doctors
planning this operation have suggested
terminating all d-class personnel in
advance to better the odds should this
experiment ever be approved though a
failure could be truly catastrophic
scp-682 has already shown itself to be
able to come back from things that are
seemingly impossible to survive
including having the majority of its
body destroyed with only atoms remaining
and yet it was still able to regenerate
back who's to say it couldn't survive a
heart attack or organ rupture too there
is also the risk of 682 gaining the
power used against it the only thing
worse than scp-682
is an scp-682 that can now teleport
around the world to kill anyone who has
ever looked at it but even with these
risks the experiment has not been
officially ruled out could one of the
foundation's deadliest ketter class
anomalies be the solution to another
it's under advisement but for right now
the foundation is keeping a very close
eye on scp-689
in more ways than one for more on the
foundation's first killer statue check
out
scp-173 the sculpture tale or watch
termination attempts scp-682 for just
how hard this lizard is to kill